as the federal shutdown continues
Democrats have coalesced around a
rationale for their continued opposition
to a border wall they're no longer
telling you that walls are too expensive
that was a laughable argument coming
from the left so they've given up
they're not telling you that walls don't
work because obviously they do everybody
knows that the problem they are now
telling us and you just heard it is that
God doesn't like walls they're immoral
as bateau a Roark noted the other day
walls quote ensure death building a wall
is the same as committing murder
well Democrat Al honimaru Minnesota has
been in Congress for only a matter of
weeks but already she strongly agrees
with this and I demand that the
president end his temper tantrums and
quest for a racist and cynical big wall
racist and xenophobic that's what walls
are and once you understand that it does
make you think they're an awful lot of
walls in this country now that we know
that they're an offense against God how
can we let them stand well that's a real
question for the city of El Paso Texas
El Paso is on the border right across
from Juarez Mexico El Paso was a calm
and peaceful and pretty city it's a
great place Juarez is violent and
chaotic it's one of the most dangerous
cities in the world how can these two
places exist side by side well simple
there's a wall between them
congresswoman Veronica Escobar now
represents the city of El Paso she just
replaced beta or Roarke Escobar says it
may be time to knock down that sinful
wall
we know that walls don't work that they
don't stop drugs that they don't stop
migration the El Paso has a wall you say
it doesn't work would you ever call for
the removal of the wall there you know I
it's it's really ugly it is I think a
monument to division we've always had
fencing along the us-mexico border it's
existed I'm a lifelong resident it
always was there but the bigger and
taller and uglier that they get they
really just become symbols a monument to
division that's what El Paso's knew
congresswoman calls her city's wall and
she's right by the way walls do divide
that's the point
of having them there are some things
people would like to be divided from
like endemic corruption and murderous
drug cartels how do you accomplish that
without walls well Nancy Pelosi has been
thinking about this recently
here's her solution and then we talk
about technology as I said several
hundred million dollars ranges from a
half a billion to seven hundred million
dollars for the technology to scan the
cars coming through the ports of entry
and that is to detect guns it's like an
electronic dog almost digit to detect
drugs guns and other contraband an
electronic dog of course how obvious it
was right there in plain sight and we
missed it the rest of us were thinking
about security and old-fashioned
medieval terms walls fences actual
living dogs but leave it to the
congresswoman from our technology
capital out in California to think a lot
bigger than that you're looking at the
solution of the future an electronic dog
brilliant the show is exclusively
obtained a prototype of the speaker's
digital canine you're watching it right
now
just kiddin me pull that off the
internet probably not so different from
the real thing though we'll see in the
meantime though let's take Nancy Pelosi
and beta or orc and the entire editorial
staffs on the other cable channel
seriously for a moment let's concede
that walls are in fact inherently
immoral how do we respond once we've
accepted that we can't simply prevent
Donald Trump from building a wall that's
not enough we've got to do something
about the countless walls of wickedness
that degrade and pollute America's moral
landscape for example the wall that
keeps poor people out of Barack Obama's
home in Washington the wall that
protects George Soros his place in South
Hampton the wall the Pelosi compounded
Napa not to mention the wall around Mark
Zuckerberg sustained in Hawaii the gated
communities of Brentwood the walled
gardens of Brooklyn level them all all
of them make them flat in fact do it
tonight before an angry God turns us all
to pillars of salt for ignoring his
anti-wall commandment speaker Pelosi
tear down these walls
once you've done that turn the bulldozer
of righteousness outward to the world
Israel for example surrounded by walls
and virtually all sides does Nancy
Pelosi know that will she withhold
billions in military aid until those
walls are gone that's a moral question
now what's the answer
and how about Tunisia and Jordan we help
pay for those countries walls we are
implicated in those walls will we pay to
take them down how much do we really
care about our souls we contacted the
speaker today to find out she didn't
reply neither the other Democrats we
called it turns out they have no plans
to eliminate anyone else's walls and
certainly not their own they just don't
a wall to protect America they don't
think our country deserves that just
yesterday the New York Times ran a piece
by a man called farad manju he demanded
the u.s. get rid of its borders entirely
no borders if ten million a hundred
million a billion people want to move
here so be it
it's not our right to keep them out it's
only our obligation to pay for it that's
the Democrats position they're telling
us that God agrees with them